era el último día de 2022 el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro anunciaba el
cese el fuego con cinco grupos armados
días después la guerrilla activa más
antigua de América Latina el ejército de
liberación nacional se desmarcaba del
pacto y no ha sido hasta un mes después
que se conocen los detalles de La tregua
con una de las mayores disidencias de
las Farc en 2016 tras el acuerdo de paz
de la guerrilla y el estado hubo
desertores que hoy buscan un nuevo
proceso como esta facción liderada por
Iván mordisco en el acuerdo destaca un
mecanismo de veeduría del Ministerio de
defensa el alto comisionado para la paz
miembros internacionales y apoyo de la
sociedad y la iglesia y otros puntos
emitidos en un comunicado
la fuerza pública seguirá ejerciendo sus
obligaciones de seguridad y defensa
nacional Así como tampoco se suspende de
ninguna manera el ejercicio pleno de
todos los poderes del Estado el
protocolo dentro de sus lineamientos
prohíbe el tránsito o permanencia del
grupo armado Estado Mayor central Farc
ep en cabeceras municipales
corregimientos inspecciones de policía
así como en vías primarias evitando
cualquier afectación a la vida e
integridad física de la población civil
Mientras tanto el lunes 13 de febrero
las negociaciones de paz con el ejército
de liberación nacional continuarán en un
nuevo ciclo en México después de una
primera ronda en Venezuela también la
semana que viene el gobierno radicará en
el congreso la ley de sometimiento la
aceptación de responsabilidad penal de
grupos armados criminales y dedicados al
narcotráfico sin estatuto político con
la ley podrán someterse de forma
colectiva y con ciertas prerrogativas en
este contexto la organización de
Derechos Humanos indepad dijo que se
siente un desescalamiento de la
violencia en Colombia por la paz total